le miel et les abeilles ça pourrait
devenir un feuilleton catastrophe car
depuis quelques années un insecticide
qu'on retrouve dans les graines comme
dans le tournesol par exemple eh bien on
cet insecticide tuent les abeilles en
cinq ans par exemple en france 45 mille
ruches ont disparu et les apiculteurs
sont très inquiets françois prix là
daniel est apiculteur dans les deux
sèvres depuis 1993 il a vu sa production
de miel fortement diminué ces fûts
verdun font donc la récolte de miel dont
un seul cette année là baissé depuis
sept ans de 80% c'est tout à fait
considérable
auparavant donc je les stocker sur deux
étages de hauteur tout le bâtiment était
complètement rempli le cas de daniel
n'est pas isolé aujourd'hui en france on
produit 25 mille tonnes de miel par an
soit 20 mille tonnes de moins qu'en 1995
les apiculteurs affirme que c'est la
faute aux pesticides utilisés pour le
traitement entre autres des tournesols
il dénonce au moins deux produits le
gard ocho et le régent fabriqué par
bayer et rhône poulenc depuis quelques
années fait que la nouvelle génération
d'insecticides en particulier le fameux
gimmie dat le prix d' est utilisé sur
différentes plantes et le cours national
particulier nous perdons chaque année 3
ou 4 100 colonies dans notre
exploitation l'imidaclopride et la
molécule active du pesticide selon
certains scientifiques de l'inra et du
cnrs
il suffit d'un milliardième de gramme de
cette molécule pour paralyser une
abeille les abeilles passent un temps
plusieurs secondes plusieurs minutes à
se gratter à se contorsionner à se
frotter les pattes et parfois même elles
ont la difficulté repartir à s'envoler
vers la russie
un constat totalement niés par la
direction de la firme bayer le fabricant
du cloud chaud il y à d'autres études
d'autres instituts tout aussi réputés
qui réfute les thèses de l'inra du cnrs
si nous avions eu le moindre doute quant
à la relation de cause à effet entre ce
produit et la malle des abeilles nous
aurions bien entendu retirer ce produit
depuis longtemps les responsables de
l'union nationale de l'apiculture
française demande à jean glavany le
ministre de l'agriculture d'interdire
définitivement l'utilisation de la
molécule pesticides tueurs d'abeilles